we are seeing an increase in coven
numbers let's welcome dr marlo hernandez
of keno health the sponsors of this next
segment as we learn more about the new
variant that is spreading welcome to the
show tell us more about the new variant
that's out there right now well it's
very concerning because this new variant
is more contagious
we think it's milder because it's about
half the incidence of that very serious
disease that leads to icu and some other
countries but we don't know that yet
here in the united states but we do know
is that it's still very dangerous it's
still code and it's more transmissible
and particularly for those who have not
had their boosters they're more likely
to get it than other variants and that
leads me to a conclusion that we're
going to see hundreds of thousands of
cases over the next few days even and
this christmas season this holiday
season we're all getting together we're
all in this covet fat team
it's very dangerous so we've got to
protect ourselves okay so what can we do
to protect ourselves well beyond just
hiding out in the cave right
we can get the booster okay if you've
been vaccinated and that means after six
months of your original vaccine
surgeries getting your additional dose
or you can
certainly protect yourself by wearing
masks the physical distance limiting
that physical contact that is something
that we certainly can do the hand
hygiene everything that we already know
but it's not like i give you a pill to
prevent it today now there are some
medicines in the horizons to treat it
but it's much better to prevent because
you know that always that onset
prevention is better than the pound of
cure let's let's go back to some of
these pills that we're seeing stories
about that were they the pills minimize
the effects of covet what do these pills
do well just like the vaccine actually
they're antivirals they prevent
replication of the virus so the vaccines
what they do they neutralize the virus
it's all about decreasing that viral
dose that your body has to fight against
so that your body can get rid of it it's
not like we can get rid of it for you
okay and so what we're seeing in the new
pills where there's merck or pfizer
we're seeing 80 90 effectiveness against
serious disease or illness even lowering
mortality and that's very exciting but
it's certainly not a hundred percent and
i'd rather be vaccinated you still have
a chance of getting it and if you get it
then you get regeneron or one of these
new pills to help you get through it
okay wait we have to wrap up it but i do
have one more question because the
holidays are here a lot of people are
planning get togethers with family
traveling to visit family
recommendations if you're going to go
see family we have a large christmas
gathering coming up what's your
recommendation that's really tough
because if there's something we've
learned from covet is the importance of
relationship of that connectedness
virtual can never replace it but
let's try to minimize it this christmas
season let's definitely wear our masks
whenever possible and let's get that
booster that's the way to show your
family love i love it doctor thank you
so much for joining us we appreciate it
and thank you to cano health for
sponsoring this segment for more
information call 702 848 287
or visit kenno health